but it's not it's not the generation
we're in today it's the choices that
women make today it's not the generation
Society doesn't make you do things you
pick what percent of women are virgins
on their wedding night that's a choice
what would you say like you you
mentioned something just a second ago
when you were like oh um before I get
something like women get take taken for
granted what's the point where you can
give be so selfless and you can keep
giving and giving and giving giving
where's that fine line between giving so
much and then just being absolutely
walked over yeah literally what do you
have to what what what what changes
what's the stopping point you know for
you like your personal opinion I think
that people that are genuinely selfless
aren't asking what they get in return
and they tend to get more and they don't
tend to pick men that treat them like
not us and even even the men that
are a little bit more of that
they usually act right for those girls